the chemo takes it out of you I mean I
feel so weak
all the time and that's not a good place
to be
Alex Trebek gives an update on his
pancreatic cancer battle during an
appearance on Good Morning America on
Wednesday sitting down with Robin
Roberts the 78 year old jeopardy hose
gets candid about the side effects of
his chemotherapy how are you doing my
oncologist tells me I'm doing well even
though I don't always feel it what I'm
not used to dealing with is these surges
that come on suddenly of deep deep
sadness and it brings tears to my eyes
I've discovered in this whole episode
ladies and gentlemen that I'm a bit of a
wuss and but I'm fighting through it
in early March Trebek announced he was
diagnosed with stage 4 pancreatic cancer
in a message to fans normally the
prognosis for this is not very
encouraging but I'm gonna fight this
I plan to beat the low survival rate
statistics for this disease truth told I
have to because under the terms of my
contract I have to host jeopardy for
three more years
one week later Trebek reportedly
returned to work on Jeopardy
and continues to keep a positive outlook
I just want to take a few moments to say
thanks to the Believe It or Not hundreds
of thousands of people who have sent in
tweets texts emails cards and letters
wishing me well following my recent
health announcement
I'm extremely touched by the warmth you
have expressed in your comments to me
I'm a lucky guy I have managed to
receive so much love from so many people
and quite often you don't get that
during your lifetime after you're passed
after you're dead people say oh he was
such a good guy we really liked him but
I'm getting that all before that event
so it makes me feel really really good
[Music]